hey everyone persia here and i am back
with jordan what's up jordan hey uh glad
to be back
glad to be talking about apex again yes
of course
and like jordan said we are back to talk
about apex
original kings canyon and original
world's edge
is going to be back in a rotation i'm
pretty excited but i also have a lot of
friends who just picked up the game
recently
and have no idea what these maps used to
look like which is
actually a wild thought to think
so we're gonna hop back and go through
the evolution of kings canyon all the
way from
day one day zero practically to where we
are
now and we have a ton of more lore to
talk about too so we're gonna sprinkle
that stuff in
as we go through these map changes as
well let's start
from the very beginning pre-season
this is basically the version of king's
canyon that everyone is going to see
when genesis hits um peaceful
for the first and last time as jordan's
notes
say here look if you have not been
following apex from day one you're about
to find
out that king's canyon has gone through
the ringer
it has been beaten and battered by
almost
every single new legend who has joined
the game but it was peaceful at the
start it was beautiful it was
lovely there were leviathans and flyers
off in the distance and everything was
kind of basically untouched
and then everything slowly begins to go
wrong
yeah slowly but surely because season
one
the wild frontier octane joins the games
and as we go into season two
this is where things start to get
interesting because we start seeing more
town takeovers um people were getting
used to the map but now is when we start
to see
little changes things just getting added
on right nothing major
it was wild when there was just this
small
tiny little landmark in the corner next
to
thunderdome in skull town it was called
west settlement
and it was basically useless for nothing
and
octane wanted to spice things up and so
he took out
that settlement and he replaced it with
the gauntlet which has
now been on king's canyon i think ever
since it's never gone away
battle charge this is where we got our
first look at
krypto who definitely added
not only a lot of lore to
apex but added more of
how that lore directly affects in-game
maps
it's like i remember like looking way
back like even though the cinematic
trailer for season two was the first
time we saw
crypto like leading up to that moment
like i remember there was like some
random hill or spot on the map where you
could find this little
computer laptop and it had like crypto
symbol on it
and people were like yo what does this
mean and people are like oh i think it's
for a new character and then we
see just the back of this character in
this trailer
using that laptop with the symbol and
we're like
yo are we getting like two characters at
once it's like no we're only getting
watson
but krypto still left his mark when he
decided to
try to hack into the arena and
accidentally destroyed the tower
that was keeping the leviathans and the
flyers out and they
just they destroy a lot of stuff they
destroyed
bridges they destroyed cascades which
were like these
smallish settlement village type things
that were
closer to the middle-ish of
the map and a few in like the more
northern
parts this also feels like a change that
like has
been kind of there since the very
beginning like it's so
hard to like even think about the fact
that there was a time
where the cage is
now like that led to a bridge that led
to the tunnels that led to the other
side where
the crater is now where skull town and
thunderdome used to be
like it was a completely different area
and
this was the first really major change
that respawn ever did
for a map where it was like oh there
used to be an easy way to cross this gap
and
now you either have to go into this
valley and dodge leviathan
footsteps or take this zipline across
where people can easily snipe you
season two is where we got our second
town takeover
because for whatever reason like the
syndicate or some of the organizers for
the apex games were like oh let's just
dig right here and it's like oh there
are some
labs underground like right here in the
middle of kings canyon
i totally remember when the voidwalker
event
uh kicked off and i got into a match for
the first time that day and i'm like
there's just a giant wraith portal in
the sky
the number of squads that would drop in
that portal every single time especially
if it was close to the drop ship but it
was hilarious right you would have some
people who would go the caustic route
they'd drop in and try to throw a bunch
of traps
maybe they'll catch some people you have
the bangalores to go in there and just
smoke the entire place and you have like
30 people just running around
in the smoke it was wild amazing it was
completely royal
that was also where we got like our next
story tease where there was this secret
room in the labs
that if you like got to it fast enough
and you broke down the door
you could see krypto actually in the
room
hacking into like the computers for
the apex games and like getting himself
a spot
like in the ship that was going to go to
some place that at the time we had no
idea what it was it had just this giant
sky hook tower and we're like oh that
looks really cool maybe they're adding a
new thing to king's canyon how naive we
were
how wrong we were we'll get into more
about that new map and
next time around but man
that was like a crazy change where it's
like yo krypto's actually in the game
you can see
him right here and we have
he has so much to answer for for blowing
up the map
season two was actually pretty chunky
right we
got more teasers on crypto we got more
teasers on where the legends would be
heading next which we would later find
out would be world's edge
we find out more about watson how she is
involved
with the apex games and created the ring
etc etc
also voidwalker that was a crazy reveal
where we found us like
yo wraith isn't even from this dimension
right
and like just even throwing that out
it's like there's a multiverse and the
titanfall apex legends universe
so much so much so we learned a lot
about kings canyon and about our legends
in season two so the next time we saw a
major change
on kings canyon was in season five
and it was a doozy it was a major
doozy because school town probably one
of the most polarizing
areas on king's canyon was destroyed
just blown off the face of the earth
literally
new apex fans you have no idea
like the ramifications of what this was
it's like we had been at
world's edge for a few seasons and even
though the new uh
map rotating feature had been added so
that we could at least go back to king's
canyon on occasion had
come in like it was still kind of a
world's edge
kind of deal for season three and season
four so season five it's like
cool we're coming back to kings canyon
it's been so
long we finally get to go to everyone's
favorite point of interest skull town
and reespawn just comes in
and blows it up like it just destroys it
and it was quite the entrance for
loba season five's new character who had
been attempting to kill
revenant as we had learned over the
course of
season four for a very long time and
she just kind of comes in and tries to
kill him
does a really bad job at it destroys
the entire southernmost corner of king's
canyon
and uh kind of flirts her way into the
apex games which
kicks off the first quest yeah the first
quest for
apex legends that was the whole time we
got
pve missions for the first time and last
time
i can't wait to see how new players
react to
king's canyon and genesis of course
salvage won't be there because salvage
was built where skulltown
south settlement and thunderdome once
were
uh offshore rig won't be there
interstellar relay will go back to its
original
relay the giant capacitor that's
basically dominating the entire central
part of the map
won't be there charge towers won't be
there because that was a thing that was
added in season five the
very nice foresty area that's
in the middle it's gonna go back to the
really burnt out
like really destroyed area it was before
like a lot of stuff happened in season
five most of the king's canyon that you
know today i think comes from the
season five changes including when
crypto decided you know i want to spy
on people around me a little bit more
i'm going to build a town takeover
and so he creates the map room which
i for whatever reason also kind of feels
like a landmark that's just been there
for a very long time but
really kinda hasn't
things seem to slow down a little bit on
kings canyon changes it isn't until
season seven
that mirage decides to bring the mirage
voyage from world's edge over to king's
canyon
i honestly feel like the mirage voyage
deserves its own episode at this point
it's been to
nearly every map now it's crashed
[Music]
and down been hilarious to see like
mirage is just trying to have a party
and have a good time and he
everywhere he goes everyone's killing
his vibe it's so funny
and then after that in season eight is
where we
start seeing more major changes so it
went on a little bit of a lull but then
boom season 8 showed up mayhem is
indeed the name of the season and of all
the
madness that happened because this is
where fuse joined the apex games
mad maggie was not happy about that at
all
and she had some things to say or
blow up in this case oh my god blowing
up fuse's ship
and then as it was crashing just also
blowing up the entire
top portion of king's canyon which
if i can say personally as an aside
thank god
because as cool as it was that it was
like yo respawn's willing to take big
risks and destroy skull town
when they took out skull town king's
canyon became way too small
so reespawn's solution to that is just
let's just destroy the entire northern
wall of this map and add a brand new
area to it and so artillery gets blown
up
which adds a whole new area which is
crash site slum lakes become spotted
lakes
the ecological cleanup and hazard
outreach
is a sign to clean up the mess which is
why there's a bunch of those
echo camps and those new observation
towers
caustic kind of starts doing his little
like psychopathic mumblings like oh
there's there's toxin in the water this
is fascinating interesting
the farm is removed and uh explosive
holds were added
in season eight another thing that just
hasn't been there since the start
but yo caustic you turned the entire
water treatment plant into your
own like horror house but like with the
caustic treatment add-on there's the
secret room that only kostik and watson
could go into and that leads into the
time to the comic where
watson's like you're going to try to
poison the city and cossack's like yeah
it's for a test you can't stop me
watson's like
the hell i can't i can definitely stop
you and it kind of
begins to them uh reconciling and fixing
their
father-daughter relationship that was
once very cute in season five and then
went
terribly terribly wrong after season
eight we haven't seen too much on king's
canyon because we've had more of a focus
over on
olympus but that doesn't mean we aren't
going to see more but luckily for anyone
who is tuning in
that did not see king's canyon in its
early you know early early days you're
going to get a chance to see that and
be prepared for the chaos because
original kings canyon i feel
was way more chaotic than what it is now
took many seasons for it to be refined
into its current state but i'm excited
for people to see it to be honest
everybody else who would also like to
see more of these videos make sure
you leave a like and subscribe and leave
a comment down below it lets us know
that you enjoy
what you're seeing thanks so much for
watching and we will catch you guys
next time
you